- I can imagine what
it's about a little bit,
but will you tell us
like the premise of it?
- Yeah, well, I'm like an
Indian nerd so when I have
a show called The Sex
Lives of College Girls,
which is what the show is about, like,
it makes you think like, oh,
did you have a sex life in college?
Which I did not, but-
- Oh yeah I was nerdy too.
- I was nerdy so like, but
I love Sex in the City.
I love the Show Girls.
And I just think that, I went
to college in the East Coast
and it just seemed like such a fun,
I hadn't, there weren't a
lot of shows like about that.
And it just seemed like a
really fun, juicy title,
but I'm a prude because I can barely
say the title without laughing.
- You giggled!
- Yeah I giggle every time
embarrassed of the show.
Not the show of the title of the show.
So I'm like,
you know, I'm still
getting used to it now.
- It's fun though,
and I think also it's probably fun
for people to watch now, too.
Cause it's like, wow, yesteryear,
when you could actually
hang out with people,
go to parties, it's like
different now 'cause of COVID.
So it's like,
it's actually awesome to see just
people hanging out
together on college campus.
- Yeah. Well shooting a
show where it's called
the Sex Lives of College Girls.
So there's like sexy situations,
which are impossible
to shoot during COVID.
So they would, everyone
had to be tested 500 times,
that it's just like very awkward.
And then it's one thing
if you're one of the performers
in it, you had to be there.
But when you're just a producer,
for a show that's about sex
and you're just watching it
on a monitor to be like, yeah,
yeah, this is good.
You're like, ah, am I like a pervert?
Like what is this?
- Should we be watching it?
- Should I be watching this?
It's college age people
making out and I'm like
observing it and being like, no, no, no.
More thrusting this time so-
- It's for, it's for the art.
- It's for the art.
Heavier breathing please so-.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah so it's been a, an awkward journey.
for me to be in.
- It looks like a funny
show though, I love it.
- I think it's going to be really fun.
I mean, I am a person where like,
I just wanted to like
laugh when I turn on TV.
I just want to see something
that's not going to depress me.
Life is so hard for everyone.
Everyone's just like trying
to get by, especially now.
And so I wanted to do
something that was really funny
and was like, I don't know, kinda-
- Escapism.
- Wish, yes, wish fulfillment, yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, speaking of sex
lives, um you posted this.
Let's show (laughing).
It was like, so you,
you said Joey and Chandler
were your sexual awakening.
- Yes.
- You know, I would say
explain, but I am you.
I loved Friends. I loved-
I love Friends.
- Yeah
- Well, look at this photo
of the two of them, right.
- I'm in.
- Peak, peak Matthew Perry.
- Yeah, yeah!
- Peak Matt LeBlanc.
- Yeah!
- And during, when they had the um,
the Friends reunion on HBO Max, like.
- Did I watch it? Yeah,
Was I probably like freaking out
that Rachel and Ross secretly had this
like weird chemistry in real life
- Yes, exactly.
Yes, and so when they did that,
there's lots of memes of
when they were, you know,
in their twenties and they're posting it.
And I saw that photo and I was transported
back to being 14 year
old, 14, 14 years old.
And just being like, oh my gosh,
if only, if only Chandler
was my boyfriend,
and I saw that photo and I was like,
this is my sexual awakening.
Well it felt like it was for,
you know, cause I'm like 40.
So for me, like, I'm like
the perfect age where-
- Me too I'm about to be 40.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it was like our perfect age that,
and I loved Steven Tyler.
I had.
- Steven Tyler.
- I was like, he doesn't know
we're going to get married,
but we are.
Yeah.
I was the weird kid with
daddy issues, apparently.
- Well when you watch the
reunion, I was like, oh,
they can like still get it.
I was like.
- Oh my God, they're funny, very witty.
Matt's been on here, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
- They're like, they're funny.
They're cute.
Like, I was like good for them.
- Well, BJ Novak was recently at a bar,
and a fan sent him Kelly
Kapoor's favorite drink.
- Yes
- That drink is a seven and seven
with eight maraschino
cherries, sugar on the rim,
blended if he can.
Have you ever had one of these drinks?
- Okay, so this is, so
I have never had one.
And this is from an episode of The Office.
So Kelly Kapoor likes the
most sugary drink of all time,
- Which I am in to.
It's a good thing her name is Kelly.
We get along, yeah.
- So it was like a seven, seven and seven.
It's like Seven Up.
I don't know what the other seven is.
- It's like Secret Seven?
Is that what it is?
- Yes, seven and seven with
seven, maraschino cherries.
It's like disgusting.
- Okay.
- But BJ had sent it,
and I've never had it.
But I've always, it sounds disgusting-
- Here's the thing.
If it's disgusting,
we're going to find out
because I made them.
- Yes!
- So here we go.
Thank you, Justin.
- Oh my God!
Thank you!
Wait!
- Only I love, blended if you can.
- Oh my God here, cheers!
- It is blended.
- Fully blended.
- Wait, the sugar on the rim.
- It's pink.
- That's a different pink.
- I'm going to get some.
- Oh my God. Okay.
- Mmmm.
Just giving me diabetes.
- Oh my God.
It's like straight up
like a, like a snow cone.
- This tastes delicious.
- It's like a, like a snow cone.
- This is like something
that you would get,
first of all, this is,
it feels like a child
would like to drink this,
which is,
- My daughter is going to see this,
and be like, why didn't you bring it home?
- Like why didn't you bring it home?
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is like something they would have
at Universal City walk.
- And that, I would definitely get,
and say it's for my kids,
but really drink it myself.
What?
No one does that.
- Thank you, Kelly,
for my awesome seven and seven.
- Your first drink, it's yours.
Well, now that we have our drinks,
Reese Witherspoon asked you
to write Legally Blonde three,
which I gotta be honest with you.
I'm very excited about that.
I love the movies.
but I'm such a fan of you,
and like your humor and your twist on it.
I'm so stoked for it.
- Thank you.
- Were you just freaking out?
- I feel like I'm writing a
Marvel movie because it's like,
it's like, Reese's Avengers, you know,
like it's her beloved character.
And she's like, you
know, Elle Woods is like,
for people like me who
love romantic comedies.
Elle Woods is like Captain America.
So I was such a fan.
And then they were like, would
you like to write the movie?
And I feel like I'm writing fan fic, like.
- I love it.
- I'm just like-
- Is it fun?
It's different though right?
- Like, I mean, I just love
the first movie is so perfect.
So it's really fun,
but it's also daunting.
But it's really fun thinking
of like Elle woods at,
you know, 43 or whatever,
what is her life like?
What did she have kids?
- But what I think is
interesting is all of the,
like our age women, like we,
we've gone through those stages.
So we're like the same.
So it's nice to see.
It's kind of cool I think.
All those same fans are going to be like,
what's happening now?
- Kelly, I hope so.
- Yeah.
I would totally watch.
I love, I love them.